questo sistema in italia e ossino
challenge tre colori di blind virtuosa
faremo stesso l'ho rivista campus più
tra i tumori di pallini comune blu
marrone ci mettiamo anche il giallo
io spero che mi capiti viola più rosa
più la rosa con il catino con troppo ma
saranno tre che dovremmo prendere qui ma
non so che mix uscirà fuori perché
vicino a te questa volta quindi qualcosa
di intuisce quello che a me piace così
vedere cruciale di tre colori
consigliatissimi commenti e altri tipi
di colori volete cioè non chiede tipi
nonché altri colori ma con cosa altro
volete che facciamo questo mezzo tre
colori colore strano questo è un mix di
colori anche se è un po strano abbiamo
rapito
dentro ci sono un bel po di colori è un
fit
comunque se ti ricordi prende tipo
accordo dovrete votare 40 persone
unico neo se vince è vitale in base alla
bellezza del live action e summer volevo
dire una cosa come in ufficio
votate sempre beh io sono contenta che
che insomma addio che siete dei fan
leali però in questo caso dovete votare
davvero chi vi piace di più come slime
non per la persona per misanesi malati
perché anche se ha fatto notare più
belle armi mattino io sono sempre ti
porta da per cento e non è contata noi
per la persona ma per lo slime mia come
è adesso scrivere a tutti quanti ma
perché davvero più bello il tour è
troppo browser che tecnica ora iniziamo
con le stacca posso vado a mischiarli to
deve scendere ora tu puoi cantare una
canzone nel frattempo questo sarebbe un
omino a sia cantante vita ok e come si
chiama se non sono nomi ricordi
caramelle no non ne voglio più
un incontro che la belva che è fatto
sono tutti qui
[Musica]
vedere la torraccia grigia con i colori
però sembra grigio adesso polizia
tricolore di tutti i colori creati
credito mista possa scambiare con te no
nel senso che io mi prendo testo di
questo o quello tocca a me
[Musica]
perché riguarda il quale si è bruciato
ma loro vanno da qui a qui ok non questo
questo dio ma non c'è niente ii secolo
ix viii io volevo il viola
vediamo appartamenti fregarvi effettiva
cosa più bella letto attentamente questa
sacca forward aggiungerei questo
diventerà parlare non è vero perché
perché se andiamo a mettere da sempre
membri dr se andiamo ad aprire la mia
stacca pochi viola vediamo un po come è
caduta la punto va beh non fa niente ma
che bello è un bellissimo lilla e
bellissimo questo colore speriamo che
speriamo che mischiato con altri colori
non diventi una schifezza
se lo domanda va bene tratta grigio ma
il tuo diventerà grigio o marrone
più color come s vai ottime verde e
mezzo validissimo dei capi abbiamo molto
male malissimo già grigio il colore
pieno di vip in alto i colori è
diventata solo green perché all insieme
dei picchi colore non fu direttore
bridge
abbiamo iniziato male con lui vediamo
carità fallo di sasso carta forbice
città e della forbice cassaforte il
verde celestre moretti lo so vorrei
verde non è vero quando non c'era dubbio
pronti allora troppo a tutti quanti
attendere ma sì questo no volenterosa
arrivando ad un bel grigio uscita
bruttissimo marrone grigio ma cos'ha
fatto fatto allora sono da qui ecco chi
sono tutti i vicini sono tutti e tre
imbecilli o b 1 2 e 3
avevo è questo vediamo la tua faccia
prima prendere il verde si fa veramente
c'è veramente non è possibile ogni sfida
sembra che lo facciamo
amanda uscirà la carica con la mia stata
poi verde vediamo messe verde
siamo tutti pronti qui a vedere commesso
e grigio
almeno verde menta e un verde abbastanza
chiaro per fortuna non è molto scuro e
un grande fermati di verde blu controllo
vediamo adesso come diretta da sempre ci
stanno bene questi regolari e qatar sono
i colori di un mostro ma il composto
finora così è bello però una volta
fischiato fatto rimane lì la quarta sta
rimanendo lilla ma rimanendo viola verde
ha ancora great dane grigia aspettare il
canto secolo cemento e un vialetto
chiarissimi sintomi quando da calcolo
reinvestirà meno pronostici ingrigito un
po io come diventa con il rosa un bel
branzino come uscirà su marrone share
per loro fare ma aspetta che appoggiato
conto sarà un caso bellissimo in
vantaggio sì sono un rote bellissimi e
tremonti mare ma trombone marrone come
differente
io spero diventi rosa dai dai dai si sta
diventando un grigio più chiaro già sta
scomparendo il romeno però che ha
conosciuto timidi veramente breve è vero
io quindi il prossimo si farà mai il
decisione proprio sei il mio chi arriva
chiaro chiaro chiaro è che io ho visto
mormore più green
quando mi sembra più chiarino il mio
chi è il round tra prima di postare le
ultime sacca posto il testimone palline
ma dopo quello dato da alcuni mesi con
il quale volta quelli zona asi la legge
ovviamente io vorrei quelle rotta oppure
queste colorate speriamo che non ci
affligge caso stavolta di un progetto
congiunto era gpp è piaciuto
20 agosto è morto vistia era parte da
qui a chi aspetta lo metterà mano lo
slime abbiamo niente da qui aumenta da
qui a cui ok poi voglio questa volta non
si come no certo il cell guarda le
famiglie sono aggiunti ben o il verde
sta solo in queste quelle mister ok
queste e jenny merda chain verde
6 perché perché sono un altro bellissimo
e presto perché sono color fortezza qui
ci sono fortunata a non farlo giusto
casa aspetta sull acqua durante l'ora
che torino che forse state portate due
perché abbiamo più di tre colori abbiamo
già i tre colori delle palline entro
mese fa ma praticamente abbiamo lo
stesso slime le stesse palline nome
stesso ruolo al pastello come stata
accesa si è però sempre colorate mia
sensibili quindi lo critica ma poco
cambierà tutto il destino dello stretto
no
milizie aspettative ci sono più di tre
contatti colori come mettono al 5 c'è il
verte il violetto il marroncino mamma
celeste
questo è un giovane di euro mischia volo
bellissimo super di ricatto speriamo che
la kafala buffet pallino
speriamo che la persona sta campo se non
cambi tutto esporre già altri come
solido e poi finalmente posso mettere
queste palline che rossano colorate
pastello sono colorate colore acceso
così è bello guardate quante belle una
meno belli ma è vero questo so più belle
quindi ho visto dio
l'arancio e il verde il verde rosa
quanti colori ci sono più di tre ore
rf lo sly il violetto arcobaleno corano
timer come lo slime arcobaleno violetto
uscirà un brad bird dei cake alla viola
vediamone dedicate come ultimo colore e
fermo l'ultimo colore sarà decisivo per
tutti e due quarto round ultim'ora e
speriamo tutti giù che ci capiti blu
perché l'arancione non lo so penso che
lo faccia marrone quindi speriamo bene
vediamo adesso si gioca tutto il primo
che c'è carta porticcio sasso che riesce
a per primo che esce
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi fa rabbia è così quali sono a rischio
un fantastico mi ricordo di ottenere
dalla consistenza capita addirittura che
qualche uno in meno gonfio e paletta non
si aspetta e li separa un po 1 acqua è
uno equa quale sei marce si rompe la
cosa dappertutto che i pronti a vedere
cosa fai la fila arancione il marrone
vediamo
anche questo per porteremo zaccheo e un
bel color mandarino
ma prima che io quindi magari esse bello
malandrino che per colore da solo
sarebbe uscito benissimo ma siccome ecco
di linda il gira un errore
no e di grigio marrone nota miti questo
marroncino no non è vero non è grigio
salmoni salmo vero salmone affumicato e
grillo ma pare diventato un po rosa
guarda quante stupendo il minuto genere
palline che sono arrivate tutte a galla
per i loro palazzi belle fatte da pollo
[Risate]
metti la facciamo scendere grigio grigio
votate con me grido grigio controlli
come sta rafforzando
non lo so prendono differenziando grigio
grigio canna
vediamola tiferò inventato un po sul
rosa pesca umani molto grigio vediamo
meglio per una ragione
[Musica]
ma vediamo un amore viola e mima la lila
attivate conti vediamo qual è il più
bello e 32 mila piccoli un bellissimo
live allora guardiamo un po il colore
scrivete voi nei commenti secondo voi
che colore è una sorta di non lo so un
rigetto un grilletto chiaro un po per
caso molto la messa in mobilità però mi
piace un sacco la consistenza e i suoni
fmr che fosse in tutte
[Musica]
tante io adoro i suoni e le folle
vediamo rappresenta il più grande il tuo
è stato bello allora parliamo del colore
sembra grigio e grigio il grigio
celestino no dai il grigio celestino che
i riflessi violetti non so se si chiede
se si vede benissimo allora le palline
si stanno super bene sembra non lo so
sembra grigio ma in realtà non è male
secondo me le palline sono super
colorate si stanno bene sentiamo un po
di suoni
mi chiamo sua sconfitta
da oggi io sento la mia scoreggia si
sognano più belli poi però guardate
guardate come soffice bello morbidoso tu
è molto più grande del mio quarto 26
piccoli o servizio vitale freschi e tuo
duro il mio bello se ufficio for free
guarda come si allunga il vino è vero
sempre fresche cosa allora nei commenti
chi vince è ora mille sono quattro
castellini stupidi care per me dei
vostri altri milioni video video
divertenti sounds like cliccare su
quello che preferite
ciao